لقد وضعوا الزجاجات في 18 عجلة ،
يرجى البقاء في الداخل ، هذا حقيقة أن
السكان الأفقر
يموتون أكثر في بعض الأحياء الأكثر ثراءً
، لقد
تم احتواؤها بشكل أكبر والأرقام
أقل بكثير من بعض الأحياء الفقيرة
التي نعمل معها  محارق الجثث
خارج الولاية لأن
أي شيء هنا لا يشبه أي
شيء رأيته من قبل
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن هذا
مرحبًا ، اسمي ماريا أدامجي ،
أتحدث إليكم من نيويورك أه التي
تعد مركزًا عالميًا  وباء covet 19 ،
هذا هو قاسم ، هذا هو ابني
البالغ من العمر 15 شهرًا
والذي يلعب بمفرده مثل معظم
الأطفال الآخرين في المتنزه
عادة لن يكون هناك
قطعة واحدة من العشب
متاحة للجلوس عليها ، إنه أمر غريب قليلاً هنا
لذا فإن الحجر الصحي في نيويورك غريب بعض الشيء
لأنه
يوجد مثل عالمين صحيح ، لذلك نحن
في عالم
نشعر فيه بالعزلة الشديدة ،
فنحن نعمل من المنزل ولكننا ما زلنا نعمل
ومن ثم هناك مثل جزء آخر
من نيويورك  ذ
لا نرى عندما تنظر إلى
خريطة كيفية تقسيم الطمع
لبعض الأحياء الأكثر ثراءً ، فقد
تم احتواؤها بشكل أكبر والأرقام
أقل
بكثير من بعض الأحياء الفقيرة ،
إنها تشبه عالمين مختلفين مثل
ii لا  تعرف على ما يحدث هناك
لأكون صادقًا ،
فهذه مدينتنا الفارغة ،
إنه أمر جنوني جدًا لقد تزوجت ، لذا
انتقلت إلى نيويورك قبل 10 سنوات
قبل ذلك كنت في تورنتو
حيث نشأت
منذ أن وصلت إلى نيويورك إنه
هكذا  غريب
مجنون مجنون مثير للاشمئزاز
مرح شجاع مكان لا يصدق وأنت
الآن مدمن مخدرات ، والآن نحن في بروكلين اعتادوا
العمل في وول ستريت
نحن نعيش في بارك منحدر في بروكلين ،
لذلك تذهب إلى بروكلين وترى مثل
شقق خمسة ملايين دولار
ومبنى واحد  هناك
مثل مشروع حيث
لا يمتلك الأشخاص وظائف ، لقد
تأثروا بشدة لأنه لا توجد
مستشفيات هناك ،
نحن محظوظون لأننا نعمل معًا في
مجال التكنولوجيا ، ومن السهل جدًا علينا العمل
في المنزل
إذا كان لديك  يجب أن تذهب إلى وظيفة من ذوي الياقات الزرقاء
وتلك أحياء ذوي الياقات الزرقاء للغاية
قبل يومين فقط ، توفي صديق عائلي جيد
من كوفيد كان في الستينيات من عمره وكانت
زوجة ابنه طبيبة
كانت في الخطوط الأمامية
لذلك أحضرتها إلى المنزل ، مرض الجميع
ولكن مع
أعراض خفيفة ومرض بدرجة كافية لدرجة أنه مات ،
نحن في موقف حيث
قال إنه مات ،
وهناك كثيرًا من الناس يقومون بدوريات يسيرون نوعًا ما فقط
من خلال التأكد من أن
الناس يبتعدون
أردنا فعلاً الخروج لأنه في
كل مكان آخر ، إذا نظرت إلى
مخططات المسار ، فقد صعدوا لكنهم
لا يحبون لعبة الهوكي بشكل
صحيح وفي نيويورك كانت مثل عصا الهوكي ،
لذلك قلنا بشكل استباقي أنك تعرف
ما يجب علينا  فقط
اخرجوا وسط هذا التخطيط
وتحدثوا عنه
أه أنتم نحن وكندا أغلقوا
حدودهم لمدة 30 يومًا
ونأمل أن يمنحوا الناس
نافذة للتنقل ذهابًا وإيابًا وخلال
ذلك الوقت
نأمل  للذهاب الى تورون  أعتقد أنه
أكثر أمانًا في كندا
بأكثر الطرق بساطة مثل
الرعاية الصحية المجانية عندما تكون مريضًا
وهذا مهم جدًا ،
فأنا خائف من أن يمرض ابني ،
فأنا خائف من أي شخص في بلدي.  تمرض الأسرة ،
فأنا خائف من مثل الجريمة والنهب
، ومثلما
أفقد الناس صبرهم ، أستيقظ كل
صباح وأقول إنه يوم جديد
سيكون رائعًا ، وبعد ذلك
بنهاية اليوم وأنا '  ما يقرب من 300 شخص ماتوا
اليوم وأشعر أن هذه الدائرة تقترب ببطء من
المكان الذي نعيش فيه ، هذا حقيقي ، هذا
حقيقي ، هذا حقيقي هنا بالنظر إلى أن
هذا صحيح في مستشفى بروكلين ،
هذا أمر حقيقي ، لقد وضعوا
زجاجة في 18 ويليام ،
يرجى البقاء داخل هذا لنيويورك الحقيقية ،
نحن خارج صالة الجنازة
التي في طريقها إلى
المدرسة وهناك شاحنتان لنقل
الجثث ،
لقد تتبعت معدل الوفيات في
المدينة التي عادة ما تكون فيها المدينة  نتسبب في
حوالي 147 حالة وفاة
يوميًا والآن لدينا يومًا بعد يوم سبعة
أو ثمانمائة
شخصًا تعرفهم يوميًا أه أه فقط من الفيروس ، ولهذا السبب غمرتنا المياه كثيرًا [موسيقى] بدأ والدي العمل في عام 1940 ، ربما يكون هناك 10 أضعاف عدد الأشخاص
في إلمير عندما
كنت أعيش هنا عندما كنت طفلاً هناك  كان هناك
12 عائلة الآن على الأرجح هناك 300
أسرة
هناك بدون عواقب
المجاري والمدارس ومواقف القمامة
وهناك عدد من المستشفيات التي
أغلقت أبوابها
على مر السنين ، مما جعل الأمر أكثر
صعوبة على
مستشفى واحد لتغطية المنطقة التي
كانت
ترعى المهرست  أصبحت نقطة محورية
لأنه في البداية
كان لديهم 13 حالة وفاة في يوم واحد
، ثم بعد أربعة أو خمسة
أيام فجأة انفجر نوعًا
ما ، حيث
تم نقل أحبائهم إلى المستشفى لأنهم
كانوا
مرضى وهم  لا يمكن الذهاب إلى المستشفى
لزيارتهم لأن المستشفى
مغلق أمام
العائلات التي تعرف أن الشخص يموت في
جسده يأتي من منزل جنازة
ونحن في خطر لذلك نقول لهم
لا يمكنني السماح لك بالدخول ،
لذا إذا ذهبنا إلى المستشفى وهذه هي
المرة الأخيرة التي رأيناها فيها بشكل أساسي إذا
انتهى بهم الأمر بالموت ،
نعم ، نعم بالضبط أنا ألتقط صورًا
للناس ، أعني أنه كان لدي عدد قليل من الناس
يتوسلون إلي
لا يعجبني جانب
المسؤولية في حد ذاته ،
لكني أشعر أن هؤلاء الأشخاص
لا تسمح محارق الجثث لأي شخص
بالداخل حتى أنهم لا يسمحون لمنازل الجنازة في
المقابر بترك شخصين إلى ثلاثة
أشخاص في المكان الذي يوجد فيه  البقاء في
سيارتك ومشاهدة الدفن من هناك ، إنه سريع جدًا
لدرجة أنه يتركهم مخدرين أو
فارغين تمامًا مثل ما حدث للتو ،
تعلم أنه قال في الصف الثالث لقد سمعته
يقول ، فلديهم ثلاثة صفوف على الأقل
وهو مرتفع  نحن نعمل مع
محارق الجثث خارج الولاية
لأنها غارقة هنا
لدرجة أنه
لا يمكنك الحصول على محرقة جثث الموتى
حتى نهاية الشهر
جزء من المشكلة هو
المدينة والمستشفيات تخبر الناس أن
لديهم  ثلاثة
أو ستة أيام لنقل
أحبائهم قبل ذلك  إنهم يذهبون لدفن المدينة ،
إنه
لا
يشبه أي شيء رأيته من قبل ولا أعتقد أن والدي قد رأى شيئًا كهذا تمامًا ، لا
أقصد أبدًا أنني تعاملت مع تحطم طائرة
911 ، هذا كل يوم فقط مع
20 جديدًا  العائلات القادمة
هل يمكنك مساعدتنا؟
سأقوم على الأرجح بنفس القدر من
العمل داخل الشهر الذي
قمت به طوال العام الماضي ، كما تعلمون
أننا نبذل قصارى جهدنا
ولكنك تعلم أن لدينا فريق عمل صغير هنا ،
هناك أربعة منا فقط
نعمل على مدار الساعة.
تعلمون كثيرًا أننا مرهقون ،
لقد عزلت نفسي هنا في منزل الجنازة ،
أنا قلق قليلاً بشأن
والدي وعمي يقولون إنهما في
حالة جيدة ولكن
نعم أحاول أن أكون حذراً أه
التعامل مع أكبر عدد من  الجثث مثل ابني
لأنني يجب أن أصرخ أعتقد أنه يفعل
الصراخ في
أنا وأنا لدينا قناع للوجه صنعته زوجتي ،
لذا فأنا أستخدم ذلك ، لذا لديّ قناع
وردي
وآخر رمادي ،
لذلك لم ترغب في أن آخذ القناع الوردي
ولكني أخبرت  لقد كنت على اتصال
بجانبي الأنثوي ، لذا
ليس لدي وقت للتفكير في الأمر ،
لدي 140
مجلدًا من الجودو جالسًا على طاولتي ، أعني أنني تناولت
لفة زبدية في الساعة السادسة صباحًا هذا
الصباح
لتناول الإفطار.  لم يأكل منذ الآن
ليس لدى المشغول وقت للبكاء ،
فربما ننظر إلى الوراء عندما ينتهي
ونفكر بشكل مختلف ، لكن آه
في الوقت الحالي ، نعم ، أنت نوع من
ذلك ،
لذا استمر
في
ذلك.  أعد تنفس أنفك إلى الوراء ، من
الصعب عليك أن تتنفس به أثناء
التحرك لأعلى ، خذ كل ما
عليك وضعه عليه ، لديها
قناعها على نعم ، هل لدينا جميعًا
قناعنا أعيش في ماونت فيرنون نيويورك وهو
تعتبر
واحدة من أفقر المناطق في وستشستر
وويستشيستر التي تصدرت الأخبار
لأن المحامي في روشيل الجديدة يعرف
باسم
هايتيان زيرو ميل إم.  إترو شمالًا إلى
مانهاتن
، وهكذا بدأت تنتشر
في نيويورك ،
هذا هو الخط المستهدف الذي تمكنا من
الحصول
على الماء والسكر ، هؤلاء هم الأشخاص
الذين ينتظرون الآن للحصول
على الماء ، أتمنى لهم التوفيق ، تعمل أختي في
مستشفى نيويورك المشيخي  من الملكات
التي كانت مريضة الآن مع تخطي kovet لأم
14 يومًا ، تأثر عمي الذي يعيش في
بروكلين أيضًا بالطمع 19. من
المؤسف
أنهم رأوا عددًا كبيرًا من
الفقراء والسود والإسبان والمختلطون
والأقليات التي تحصل عليها
، يموت السكان الفقراء أكثر
لأنه
في الظروف اليومية عندما تذهب
إلى مستشفى
في ولاية نيويورك وربما في أي
ولاية أخرى ،
فإن أول شيء يطلبونه منك هو هل
لديك تأمين
على الأربعة أو الخمسة أشخاص مختلفين  في المرات
التي تم فيها تسريحي
لم نتمكن من الحصول على تأمين صحي ،
نعم يقولون لك أنه يمكنك الاحتفاظ
بتأمينك الصحي
ولكن إذا كنت لا تعمل ، فكيف يمكنك
تحمل
مثل 1500 أو  2000 تأمين
لا يأخذون قضيتك على محمل الجد
عندما لا يكون لديك تأمين لأنه
في نهاية
اليوم تنظر المستشفيات في كيفية
حصولهم على بلدان مدفوعة الأجر مع رعاية صحية شاملة
ربما تنظر في علاج الناس
على مستوى أكثر وقائية  وهو
دفع تعويضات أقل للمستشفيات التي
يقيِّمونها بناءً على عدد السكان ،
وعدد المستشفيات التي لا
ينبغي أن تكون موجودة في الولايات المتحدة ، إنه
يركز على
الأموال لدينا مستشفى واحد في مستشفى مونتفيوري ماونت فيرنون
ومن العام الماضي كانوا
يكافحون لإغلاقه
يشعرون  أنها لا تكسب ما يكفي من
المال ، لذلك
فهي ليست ضرورية على الرغم من أنها المستشفى الوحيد
في ماونت فيرنون وهي منطقة فقيرة مكتظة للغاية ،
أعتقد بالتأكيد
أنه نظرًا لأن المستشفيات
تهدف إلى الربح ،
فهي في المناطق التي توفر لهم
المزيد من الدخل.
غني أنا أعيش في الجانب الجنوبي من
ماونت فيرنون
أنا لست ثريًا وهذا يعتبر منطقة فقيرة
سيئة
أم تعلمون أين
يتم إطلاق النار على الناس في متجر الزاوية
وأم حسنًا ig  أنت بمعنى ما
تقريبًا تصبح محصنًا منه ،
فأنت محصن من حقيقة أنه حسنًا ،
سيغلقون المستشفى الوحيد
وتقبل الناس
[موسيقى].
إنه لأمر محزن أن أقول ، لكني أتساءل متى
لم ينته كل
هذا  سوف نعود جميعًا إلى
العمل كالمعتاد ،
وآمل أن نخرج من هذا كوننا
ألطف مع بعضنا
البعض ونترك أنظمة المستشفى تركز على
الرعاية الصحية عالية الجودة وليس الربح فقط
وأننا
لم نعد نرى بعضنا البعض أثرياء أو  فقير
أو أنك تعرف الأسود مقابل الأبيض
لأننا جميعًا نموت بسبب ذلك
لا يميزك